as far back as I can remember I wanted  to be part of London part of the world's  greatest city at its grandest moment and  if you believe that you're a bloody fool  science technology progress it's a  devil's deal  it's how we build a better world  when you steal from the rich it's  criminal but stealing from the poor  that's capitalism  so we fight for justice we fight to  survive  you might not be looking for war but war  is looking for you if it finds me  operating the lads  for my brother  my sister  for London  for family Assassin's Creed syndicate  join the family get rewards reserved now  for exclusive access to the Darwin and  Dickens conspiracy available October  23rd